Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
They're finally working on the Batman 2 again
And there's a new report
that Hush is going to be the main villain,
or at least one of the major villains.
There were a couple of Easter eggs
in the first movie directly calling out,
and they borrowed
a lot of the storyline for Riddler.
So there were a lot of people
that just assumed
they would eventually do the character.
there were so many rumors that even Matt
Reeves came out and actually specifically
talked about the host character.
There have also been a few reports
about some of the other major characters
and villains are doing.
I know there's a bunch of questions
about this, too,
because if you're a long time host
fan from the comics,
they kind of did most of that storyline
for the Riddler character
Remember, though,
this is all meant to be separate
from what's happening with James
Gunn's rebooted DCU,
his Batman brave in the board movie,
a totally different version of Batman
and everybody still pulling for Jensen
Ackles to be the DCU version of Batman.
that Batman will be the one that's
connected to the new Justice League.
The overarching stories not the Matt
Reeves, Robert Pattinson Batman.
So don't worry we'll break it all down.
It's not quite as confusing as it sounds.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Like I said, the writers strike is over.
The actors strike might be done
pretty soon.
Hopefully they'll figure that out
then we'll start getting way
more announcements
about a lot of these big movies
coming out,
not just the DC movies,
but just like all movies in general.
but a lot of you
probably seen the big talk about Batman
hush in your fees recently.
Hush is probably
one of the biggest most popular
Batman villains from recent history
that they haven't really done
the live action movies yet.
there've been a couple versions
of the characters
in the animated movies, in the TV shows,
like there was the Batman
Hush animated movie,
but that changed the original ending
from the original Batman
Hush comic book storyline.
It was a little controversial.
I wasn't a huge fan of the changes,
But generally the animated DC movies
have been pretty solid on average.
they also did a version of Hush
on the Batwoman TV show in the Arrowverse,
like on the CW network.
I didn't watch the vast
majority of the Batwoman show
and they made a few changes to the host
character,
but their version of Hush was a little bit
closer to the original comic book version,
that one was depicted as a former
childhood friend of Bruce Wayne's,
who became a real estate mogul
with a grudge the harbored against him.
he had the surgery to change his face
to look exactly like Bruce Wayne.
And then like the comic book version,
he went about systematically
trying to destroy
Bruce Wayne's life, take his company,
and destroy his life as Batman.
The funny thing about that
version is he was actually more famous
for being the closest.
We actually got to seeing Bruce Wayne
Batman's face in the arrow
versus the actual arrow version of Batman
that they kept talking about for years.
But we never actually saw Stephen Amell.
And a lot of the other actors say
that Jensen Ackles for like a hot second,
almost became that live action
version of Batman
like he wanted it to be Jensen Ackles.
But for whatever reason it just
didn't work out like the powers that be.
The regime at Warner Brothers
wouldn't allow them
to actually do live action Batman the way
that they wanted to in the arrowverse.
So you can watch that Batwoman
version of Hush at Your Own Risk.
And there was a lesser version
that the Gotham TV show did.
He was Thomas Elliot,
but we never saw him become
hush is an adult later in the timeline
because that show was all about Bruce
Wayne
before he became Batman when he was a kid.
And they did the Smallville thing
where he only puts on the Batman suit
in the very last episode
after a time jump like Smallville
literally did that exact same thing.
Matt Reeves has an interesting connection
that goes way back with the whoosh
character just in general to the original
comic book version in real life.
Matt Reeves, screenwriting teacher,
when he was in college, was Jeph Loeb,
the person who wrote Batman Hush.
He also wrote The Long Halloween
in a lot of the first Batman
movie was inspired by the long Halloween.
So the Easter eggs have come full circle.
normally, you would expect Jeph Loeb
to have some sort of cameo scene
in the movie at that point,
but I don't think there was.
If you did think you spotted Jeph Loeb
somewhere in the movie,
let me know the whoosh
storyline that they gave to the Riddler in
the first movie was his whole backstory.
Growing up alongside Bruce Wayne
in the orphanage funded by Thomas
and Martha Wayne.
Like you see, the Riddler is a little kid
here next to Bruce Wayne.
It's a little kid.
in the idea and Matt Reeves Batman movies
is that Tom is in Martha
Wayne turned the old Wayne Manor house
into an orphanage
back when Bruce Wayne was young
in the Riddler just came to live there.
then they explain
as part of the whole plot
with the Wayne Fun during the movie
Falcone and the Mob then turning the fund
into their own personal piggy bank.
The crime families in Gotham,
because of that.
And Thomas Wayne's murder,
the orphanage lost its funding.
The children were all forgotten,
including the Riddler,
who lived a terrible life,
causing him to develop a grudge
against the Wayne family
and all the other powerful families
in Gotham.
Once he became an accountant
for the Wayne Fund.
Learning what pretty much all the powerful
people in Gotham were doing
because they were connected to the fun.
Not just the Wayne family.
Like he hated the Wayne family
because of what they did to him as a child
or what he thought that they did to him.
but in the movie, they turn into a much
larger thing where his grudge was against
all the people in power in Gotham,
not just the Wayne's.
then during the movie, the reporter
that Falcone kills for Thomas Wayne
to prevent him
from leaking information about Martha
Wayne's mental illness was named Elliot.
And during the Riddler's viral video
he made for Thomas Wayne
across the screen, it literally writes
the word hush So pretty much
everybody was like he's
obviously referencing the storyline later.
During Batman's conversation
with the Riddler in Arkham Batman, things
just for Hot second.
The Riddler has learned
his secret identity is going to out him
making himself famous.
Riddler keeps repeating
Bruce Wayne's name in a weird way,
but just as Batman thinks it's all over.
No more Batman.
After this river reveals
that he's just lamenting the
he and Batman were almost able
to kill Bruce Wayne.
So they almost had him, like the Riddler
almost figured out that he was Batman.
in in the
original storyline in the comics,
Riddler is largely to blame for the events
of the entire storyline in the damage
he's able to do.
The Riddler had terminal cancer.
He uses the Lazarus Pit to heal himself
in the effects of the Lazarus Pit
caused him to deduce that Batman's true
identity is Bruce Wayne.
So when the comic book version,
he did figure out the truth.
comic book
Riddler goes about orchestrating a plot
to take him down by using Thomas Elliot,
Bruce Wayne's
childhood friend who still harbors
a grudge against him
for the downfall of his own family.
and because Tom, as Elliot's mother,
is suffering from a terminal illness,
the Riddler uses the knowledge
that the Lazarus Pit in healing her
to get Thomas Elliott on his side.
And they go about systematically
trying to destroy Bruce Wayne's life
in public, in his life as Batman at night.
so even though the host character
figured out that it was Bruce Wayne
and went about trying to destroy his life,
really
it was the Riddler pulling the strings.
But because there were so many Easter eggs
during the first Batman movie.
Matt Rees later clarified that
that reporter that was killed named
Elliott was not literally meant
to be his version of the Thomas
Elliott Hush character.
Just a wink at the whole storyline.
and because that reporter is dead
in present day,
If he were actually the host character,
they wouldn't be able to use hush
in future movies if they killed him
offscreen in the side story.
So it would have been a big bummer. no.
At the time that he was talking about
this is a couple of years ago,
you have to remember,
he says it would be cool
to do the character in a future storyline.
So it makes sense now
a couple of years later
that they would choose to introduce
the host character in a much bigger way.
Let me know in the comments if they do.
The host character in the Matt
Reeves Batman sequels,
how do you want them
to adapt the character
if they already gave
a lot of that storyline,
a lot of the vibes of that storyline to
the Riddler character in the first movie,
and remember one of the differences
between the Matt Reeves version of Batman
like the Robert Pattinson Batman
in James Gunn's new DCU version of Batman
and Batman Braving the boat
is that Matt Reeves take
is meant to be way more down to earth, way
more realistic in the Christopher
Nolan kind of way.
like imagine a much more comic booky
version of Christopher Nolan's real world
vibes of Batman.
James Gunn's version of Batman.
Batman braving the ball will be like
the way more over-the-top, way
more comic book
version of Batman for example.
They're doing Damian Wayne in the movie.
You can't get more
comic books than doing Damian Wayne,
There been a couple reports
about other major characters
that they might be introducing
in that Batman too.
In the Batman sequel movies.
but most theories right now
in Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson
have definitely thrown some fire on this.
Gasoline So a lot of people at the time
thought that an implied that Mr.
Freeze would be the main
villain Matt Reeves just said
even the idea of something like Mr.
Freeze. Such a great story, right?
So a lot of people were like,
Wait a minute,
does that mean he's actually doing Mr.
Freeze in the sequel?
The monster who took you from me
will soon learn that revenge is a dish
best served cold and The other big news is
that Matt Reeves is supposed
to introduce Clay Baze during the movie,
but he's not going to be the main villain.
Most people think that he's
going to be a version
of the original Clayface,
the Golden Age version.
The character called Basil Carlo.
not the shapeshifting metahuman. Clayface.
Matthew Hagen.
That's who most people think of
when they think of Clayface.
the reason why everyone's expecting
the original Clayface is
just because he's more of a real world
down to earth, kind of Clayface.
And that's the whole vibe of the Matt
Reeves Batman universe.
so far, we haven't seen any actual
metahumans in the world of the Batman yet.
So everything's been tech based,
at least so far.
The Basil Carlo Clayface was based on real
life, Boris Karloff and Basil Rathbone.
Carlo was meant to be a B-list actor
driven, insane
when he hears that they're remaking
his classic horror film without him.
during that movie, he played the villain
who is called Clayface,
and he puts that costume back on again,
killing all the actors who are
in the remake in the order that they got
killed in the original movie.
then eventually Batman
and Robin are able to stop him.
and when we get to the Batman three,
we might even get the Court of Owls
as the main overarching villains,
which they've done in the animated movies.
They did them on the Gotham TV show,
but they haven't been done
in any of the live action movies yet
in the cast.
We're hyping them up.
After the last Batman movie came out,
there were a lot of Easter eggs
and references to the Court of Owls
during the first movie.
That's why the actors
were talking about it, like, yes,
there was a lot of court of appeals
in there.
Thomas and Martha were leaders
of the Court of Owls in this timeline.
Like that one.
Oh, that's of
I was definitely kind of thinking
it's probably going to be in the sequel.
It definitely seems nice. Mommy,
I'm not sure.
Just guessing, I guess.
Keep saying
good thing it's not in this film.
Or is it?
Or is Most of you probably seen some Robin
talk in your feeds recently.
I know everyone's been fan casting.
Timothee Chalamet is a version of Robin.
He did talk about being Robin a while ago.
after seeing him in Dune, he could
actually do a pretty bad as Robin.
But the thing is, though, the report
is that during the Batman to Matt Reeves
is going to introduce a version
of Dick Grayson who is only 13 years old.
Zack Snyder did introduce a version
of Robin during Batman versus Superman.
But it was Dick Grayson, and he was killed
before the events of the movie.
So this new version of Robin
that we're going to see
will be the first living version
that we've seen in the movies since Batman
and Robin with Chris O'Donnell's
Robin in George Clooney's Batman,
who we also just saw
at the end of the Flash movie
I'll do more videos for the Batman too,
and the other upcoming DC movies.
When we get more information,
click here to learn about Robin
potentially showing up in the movie
and click here for my full Loki Season 2
Episode 1 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!